uh here now with more house oversight
committee chairman James comr himself
all right let's explain this I noticed
the media is going after you hard saying
that well that that doesn't prove
anything that's only a loan repayment uh
from Joe there an awful lot of loan
repayments that they talk about I would
imagine though Congressman correct me if
I'm wrong if it's a loan repayment
wouldn't we have a record of the loan
being made have you ever been able to
get that
information absolutely not and of course
if you made a loan to someone you would
have a check going out to that person in
addition to the check coming back for
the so-called loan repayment that's what
that email was we talked about on your
show last week Sean when the bank
questioned Hunter Biden about what was
the reason for the $5 million wire from
China he apparently told the loan
officer it was a it was a loan so the
loan officer said well we're going to
need documentation to prove to the bank
examiners it was a loan do you have loan
documentation he said no so we're
supposed to believe believe that China
gave Hunter Biden a loan for $5 million
if you look at the last four payments
that we found with ties directly to Joe
Biden they amount to a half a million
dollars and in every instance they've
said this was a loan repayment and and
that's just hard to believe Sean unless
you've got documentation to prove that
it was a loan which obviously according
to the emails from the banks they do not
but whether it was a loan or not it's
not important Sean what matters is the
way the money was paid to Joe Biden was
directly through influence pedaling and
now this is the second payment or series
of payments to Joe Biden that came
directly from China there's no disputing
that even the white house isn't
disputing the money to repay Joe Biden
if in fact it was a loan came from China
okay you say you and your committee have
identified all of these shell
corporations now a corporation and an
LLC if they are legitim imely doing
business you would see business activity
of some kind would you not have you
found associated with any of these shell
corporations that you are describing
them as have you seen any real business
activity legitimate business activity no
legitimate activity uh most of the shell
companies don't have a single asset
again that was mentioned in the bank
email that we talked about on your show
last week the bank examiner said uh he's
supposedly running in this shell company
and investment firm but they have no
Investments and the other shell
companies they don't have any assets but
we do see wires we see lots of wires
from bad people in bad countries around
the world and one reason we wanted to
POS Hunter Biden we want to say what did
you do to receive this income if it was
in fact lobbying if he was a lobbyist
for China then that's that's called a
foreign agent and he's an unregistered
foreign agent and that's a that's a
penalty of of up to 5 years imprisonment
and $250,000 fine and Joe Biden then was
receiving direct benefit from his son
being an unregistered foreign agent so
you could make a strong argument that
Joe Biden violated the far laws as well
let me ask you about the subpoena
because obviously our friends in the the
media mob don't quite understand what a
subpoena means uh but certainly I would
argue Steve Bannon understands it and
Peter Navaro understands it a subpoena
compels somebody to come into Congress
to be deposed uh that usually takes
place behind closed doors that is the
normal procedure correct that's correct
100% of the time okay and they were
saying that you don't want to do that
we're willing to do it publicly but not
behind closed doors I would assume there
probably are questions you could ask uh
in private in a deposition that you
would not be able to ask publicly is
that true sir that's true both quality
and quantity of questions in a public
hearing where where you have 25 members
they each have five minutes each that
includes the time to ask the question I
mean you you might get 35 maybe 40
questions in if everything works out
perfectly in a deposition we can ask six
seven 800 questions to Hunter Biden and
look we have over 20 shell companies we
have 20 plus thousand pages of Bank
documents we expect to get uh 82,000
emails in pseudonyms we have lots of
specific questions that we need to ask
the president son and the president's
brother and you just don't have enough
time in a public hearing we will have a
public hearing and these depositions
will essentially be public because there
will be transcripts and we will
vote to be clear you're willing to have
both now let me go to the issue of of
energy and oil because they they seem to
come into play Big Time in terms of this
business Enterprise we know Joe bragged
that he leveraged the billion dollars in
spite of what Obama administration
policy was and
in October of 2015 we know that Joe
talked to barisma Executives with his
son while they were in Dubai 5 days
before he leveraged a billion dollars to
get the prosecutor fired we know the
prose we know barisma Executives needed
Washington DC help or the Biden brand as
Devon Archer referred to it uh and we
know that Joe got the guy fired in six
hours and that man his son continued to
get paid he had no experience uh and
apparently was addicted so admittedly
addicted to drugs at the time uh and
then in the case of CFC the oil and gas
giant out of China right directly
related to the Chinese the Communist
Chinese uh that's the WhatsApp message
that said uh I'm sitting here with my
father why have you not fulfilled what
we've asked you to do and and a threat
is made and we expect a call and what
happened five days later but $5 million
was sent to one of those accounts
correct that's 100 100% correct so what
so if you don't have any experience in
that field of endeavor why would you
make millions of dollars can someone
explain that to me no that's what we
want to hear from Hunter Biden what
exactly did you do what services did you
provide not just with barisma but also
with the Chinese we know according to
Tony balinsky who was also supposed to
be in on that CFC uh they wanted to come
in and start buying interest in American
companies energy companies in particular
but there are laws that prevent that so
they hired the bidens to help them
navigate bureaucracy to help them open
doors that that were shut to anyone
related to China so the bidens were
essentially going to work for China
that's what the company was that Joe
Biden was going to get 10% of and we
proven that Joe Biden that $40,000 check
came through that entity where Joe Biden
was supposed to be uh 10% owner just
like Tony balinsky said all right
chairman comr thank you we appreciate
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else